whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that that one that one that one
okay no they didn't hey guys I'm Ryan
Wright and I'm Dan Seibert so we're
checking out the trailer today for Final
Fantasy seven beery made the
announcement
okay I was [ __ ] driving when the Sony
press conference was going on so I don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening but do
it do the thing do the thing did you do
the thing long ago we looked upon a
foreboding the sky
the memory of the star that threatened
all burns eternal in our hearts
[Music]
in its wake in an age of silence yet
with each fond remembrance those
encountered were not forgotten that
someday we would see them again perhaps
it is no more than wishful thinking
[Music]
but after the long calm there are now
the beginnings of a stir the reunion at
hand may bring joy it may bring fear but
let us embrace whatever it brings for
they are coming back at last the promise
has been made this is this a [ __ ]
[Applause]
the miniature shot of the crab they were
losing their [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not the
biggest Final Fantasy player so I could
but I know that fans of Final Fantasy
love Final Fantasies that I'm not
judging you for freaking out like a
little [ __ ] just now oh dude they're
gonna have to clean up so many seats
drop holy [ __ ] because they [ __ ] their
pants as we here I'm blind and
everything oh and they came just
everything they just holy just lost all
their bodily fluid you're gonna have to
clean up this holy [ __ ] like I'm still
trying to process because this has been
something that's like been in the
[ __ ] works for years this has been
one of the most demanded remakes of all
time a lot of remastered or remakes are
not demanded yeah this was demanded this
was this was demanded it's not just a
remaster this is full-on remake Full HD
graphics like they had done like
remastered versions and people were like
oh cool it's HD but it's still polygon
II this is straight-up HD full next-gen
graphics [ __ ] Final Fantasy 7 this is
that's pretty cool that is pretty cool
I'm one of my top 5 list it was number 2
is a Final Fantasy 7 HD remake that's
what I wanted
yeah cuz when I first heard it I was
like alright but now that you're talking
about it I'm like yeah Dan's good boy
then has good points here this is my
head whoa damn calm down Dan oh yes I
have my wallet in my pocket do you want
it now they want my money now I'll put
my money now Dan will suck your dick
anyway guys thanks for tuning into the
real rejects agree to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Dan's gaming channel that
sibber channel and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine oh
no it's just what
Jelani broth tin so I've subscribed to
you since you had four thousand subs
Congrats for making a hundred thousand
well we're almost at like 200 thousand
at this point so late Congrats there but
thank you Jelani that's really kind of
you since four thousand subs huh damn
pretty impressive like you really stuck
around
Jelani looking at your photo I'm not
gonna show you guys are clearly kid but
you look like a very angry person like
you you look you know the problems you
know the problems mm mm-hmm
he's gonna kick your ass someday but you
can't see his crotch out like oh come on
don't worry I'm not trying to photo so
it's okay to say